you regularly ask questions on your
podcast is that something you might do
you have any questions that you might
want to ask me
yes i do this all the time i do with
bill burb i have two podcasts one two
bears one came with tom sagura and then
bill burt
with bill burr and burr is always good
to ask questions like what would you
rather
uh hit a hole-in-one or hit a walk-off
home run
oh walk-off home run right yes
that's obvious to me hole-in-one would
just feel like
just pure chance walk-off home run feels
more like skill
and i would love just dropping the bat
and being a total douche about it
do you know what i mean i would love
just dropping the bat and putting and
really taking my time going around the
bases and
to the point where the pitcher would
maybe charge me come at me
i would totally play it up i would love
a walk-off home run
all right what about dunk or speak
french
uh man that's a good one i'm gonna go
with speak french
or can i have speak french as i dunk but
only as i'm dunking i can speak french
in that moment when i'm dunking i'm
fluent in french
so when i go up and i dunk i
just start talking about descartes and
moliere
and everyone around me under the
basket's just like what the
what is this this is incredible and then
when i'm when i come back down again
i and i've dunked the basketball i no
longer speak french
okay here's here's my favorite one and
it's gonna take a little thought okay
so i'll answer first but i'll put it up
to you this is me and bill's favorite
one
you get to drive a brand new car you can
time travel to any time period
and drive the car of your dreams right
when it was released
and what music would you listen to
driving that car around
now i would go to like 68
69 and i would get a cadillac
convertible
big big long one and i would listen to
the rolling stones okay i would time
travel to 1923
but i'd be driving a car from 1925.
okay it's just a two-year difference
it's just a model and and it's slightly
different and i would be playing a
song that wasn't it's like a rudy valley
song
that hasn't come out yet but it's only
two years off
so i've gone to all the trouble to time
travel and have the machine i want but
instead of going back
to uh 1620 and being worshipped as a god
for having this machine i'm showing up
and people are like
say that looks like a 1918 you know 1920
model t and i'll say
no it's not chum it's a 1922
model d and then they'll say is that
rudy valley singing and i'd say yes
but this won't be released for four
months
button up when the wind blows free
take good care of yourself you belong to
me
i don't know i love wasting people's
time and that would be a huge waste
a huge waste of time travel a huge waste
of time
travel oh that's that's a perfect answer
well you know it's what i do it's a it's
a terrible waste
of the whole concept but that's what i
want to do